all right America it's Monday morning if
you're out of milk and out of things to
talk about we can help you with one of
those problems time now for what to
watch blad good morning good to see you
all happy Monday
we're working from home we're providing
that extra joke that you might need in
the morning by taking a look at some of
the stories we think you'll be talking
about including this a demonstration in
st. Louis led to a heart-pounding scene
outside the home of one of the mayor's
neighbors you can see a man and a woman
pointing a pistol and what looks like an
assault rifle like the crowd yesterday
the couple was confronting hundreds of
protesters who passed through their
gated community to urge mayor Lyta
Crewson to resign on Friday during a
Facebook live event Crewson read the
personal information of demonstrators
who want the city's police department
defunded more than 40,000 people have
signed an online petition demanding the
mayor step down the video has since been
deleted and Crewson has apologized she
also said the names and addresses she
read out Tony are public information and
luckily with regards to that video no
one was hurt yeah no one was hurt in
that video with the the gun on the porch
but that information while it may be
public it wasn't as public as being read
out loud there's a difference between it
being technically accessible and being
broadcast out there so I'm glad the
things went in a safer direction but it
could have gone in a better direction
from the beginning